keegan aiken ready to start this one
you're looking to pick up his first
victory of the year making his 12th
start shohei ohtani digging in to start
things out as ohtani lifts a high drive
to right field santander back watching
and it's gone number 41 for major league
baseball's home run leader one-nothing
halos
shohei homer's his first bat homer now
at every american league ballpark for
shohei ohtani a majestic home run on the
mound for the halos 25 year old right
hander jaime perea looking to better his
record over the 500 mark
santander takes that slider and loops it
out to shortstop for mayfield a one two
three start to the afternoon for jaime
berea
into shallow left v.j stewart's roaming
oh and he can't make the catch lost it
in the sun see when you do good things
good things happen your way
a fly ball that's going to be now falls
in for a hit just lost it in the high
sky as they say
full count pitch on the way and he
struck him out big strikeout with two on
and nobody down yeah the best velocity
fastball of the day so far by keegan
here's another strikeout so back-to-back
case
back-to-back strikeouts and as ahead of
lagar is one and two one-nothing angels
second inning two outs the pitch
fastball strike three code how about
that
keegan aiken the hit by pitch the single
and then he gets nasty striking out
marsh mayfield and laguaris to keep this
a one-nothing game
and a called strike three taken by
aureus so i i guess the corners might be
a little wider than the north south part
of the zone today
on a couple of bounces for fletch to
retire the side nothing comes with the
one out walk we're on to the third
inning today one nothing angel
he baited him into a bad breaking ball
here ah change-up missed so ball four
ohtani is aboard
and swung on and miss walsh down on
strikes so after the lead off walk three
straight outs angel's up one nothing
jumai got his first oriole hit last
night in the seventh inning there's a
base hit down the left field line watch
that speed he'll turn this into two
flying around first and standing up with
a double jamai jones there's his first
extra base hit as an oriole there you go
calvin gutierrez with the runner now at
second
right side into right field for a base
hit jones gets the green light here he
comes here comes the throw
and he slides he's safe
throwback to first they got gutierrez
rounded the bag got a little too
aggressive they throw behind him and get
the out but it's a base hit rbi for
kelvin gutierrez and we're tied at one
mullins bounced out to first is only at
bat
cedric drops a bunt that's a dandy put
it in your pocket you won't get him
saw a lot of that last year and a
terrific bunt for a base hit for mullins
there it's a big that's a huge lead
[Applause]
and mount castle strikes out
big strikeout for berea went back to the
fastball to get him his second of the
game
1-2 threw it by him at 93 for the
strikeout two down
1-2 mayfield swing and a miss aitkin
finally changes it up with the change-up
back-to-back strikeouts ends the top of
the fourth
payoff
mancini swings he drives it up the
middle gap for a base hit
lead off single trey mancini pitch
number six
four
so birds got something going here two on
nobody down
and they're fourth
[Music]
and there it is face hitting the right
mancini around third they're sending
them here comes the throw
it's there
and he's safe now suzuki looked into the
dugout he may want a challenge here
thought the ball beat him ben but he got
in
joe madden says hang on boys
yeah that didn't take long is that the
quickest check of a play at the plate
ever
yes
andrew wants to pitch
seven games as an angel this year
including working in the opener here on
tuesday night
there's a pitch in there on a 1-2
delivery and that is a called third
strike so wants comes in and gets the
second out in the inning
and jones pops that one up
fletcher to retire the side despite two
hits in a walk the orioles are held off
the scoreboard in the fourth lagara is
off first with one away water going they
got a chance throw to second and he is
out of there lagaris broke early mancini
down to jones
for the put out and two down
and this bounce to shore gloved by arias
and the angels down in the fifth so a
leadoff
base runner again but no run still tied
at one
3-2 pitch up high
and mullins with a walk with one down
[Applause]
and ball four so a walk to mount castle
back to back walks
orioles in business so you still have
two men out there without two outs and
mancini up in this 1-1 game 2-2 on the
way
chopper up the middle and it's into
center field mullins will score rbi base
hit for mancini mount castle gets to
third and the orioles take a 2-1 lead
there's your base hit runners in scoring
position orioles have been really good
so far today now three for seven and
continues the inning for d.j stewart
who's been very patient today as he
typically is drive into the gap in left
center that's down
mount castle scores mancini into third
he'll hold him up right there and d.j
stewart delivers a two-out double to
drive in a run and it's 3-1 orioles jake
petricho will try to prevent any further
damage so it's 3-1 base is loaded as
petricha faces the right-hander severino
initial offering belted deep center
field this ball is climbing it is out of
the bullpen it is a grand slam and the
aerials have added separation against
the angels 7-1 a pitch is up and
severino clubs it over the walnut center
10th home run of the year for pedro
severino
a six-run fifth inning and a 7-1 orioles
lead
[Applause]
it's that on the nose that's a base hit
into the left field corner haze around
first he'll go to second
austin hayes
back-to-back doubles one last night and
then his first at-bat tonight he doubles
ramona rios he's been on back on base
twice
right side and into right center for a
base hit around third austin hayes here
he comes here comes the throw and he
slides in safe as it gets away from
suzuki
marias will stay at second with an rbi
base head
[Applause]
there's a breaking ball yep
two down two strikeouts in the inning
97 98 on the inside part of the plate
you followed back up with this one full
count two out so tony will be on the
move
he goes payoff pitch strike three
and jorge lopez strikes out the side in
the top of the eighth
right side off the glove of walsh
gutierrez around second he'll get to
third mullins
hustling the second and he's in wow
cedric really
hustle that play into two bags
and the orioles set up runners in second
and third base for ryan melk castle
hit well left field
hustling over won't get there adele
one runs in mullins read it off the bat
here he comes he'll score
and it's two rbis for ryan mouthcastle
with a single to left field
[Applause]
hayes
left field getting down and it's a base
hit
austin two for two
and now aureus is going to come up
that's it well
deep right field way back
hits off the wall
mount castle in they're going to hold up
hayes and arias has another rbi with a
double off the wall sabarino's the
eighth man to hit in the center
that's it well center field marsh coming
hard won't get there two more runs in
and severino has a six rbi game
that's a good day at the office man i
would say so two swings that just six
rbis lopez trying to close it out
and he does he does strike three looking
four strikeouts and two innings of work
for lopez so he finished what keegan
aiken started orioles win their first
series in a month
13-1 in this one